hallo leute willkommen zurück zu einer
neuen episode kari antwortet wir sind
heute am gab dann in windhoek um neue
fahrzeug waren und ich zeige euch mal
ein bisschen wie das hier aussieht
es ist einfach eine lampen also wie ein
see und leute treffen sich hier zum
grillen und das haben auch gerade mal
wieder installiert ab leute capella band
ganz uns etwas mehr über diesen
wunderschönen ort es heißt sie denn sie
dann aber in völlig dieses dorian knapp
denn man kann hier kommt ein bisschen
trinken die leute grillen wir zeigen
euch mal plötzlich wird das irgendwann
das einzige problem ist an der
geschichte
es sind zu viele ameisen wählen ich bin
schon mehrmals hat gebissen worden
da seht ihr gleich im hintergrund seht
ihr wie die leute auf den tischen stehen
wegen den ameisen starten wir mit fragen
1 kalender was ist denn heute frage eins
also freiheit einzig durch ein wichtiges
sprache
sixx ist deutsch eine richtige sprache
dein ernst alter ist es auch eine gute
frage denn ich habe mich auch gefragt
wenn wir unser projekt er zufällig
gestaltet und früher habe ich immer
gedacht wer zur hölle lernt eigentlich
deutsch aber deutsch ist die vierte
meist gelernte schreiner welt wer hätte
das gedacht ich zunächst nicht
und falls keine wirklich erklärt
meistens geblockt englisch französisch
spanisch alles andere weniger
also deutsche sehr populär und
vielleicht liegt das daran dass
deutschland so tolles wetter hat ja doch
was gefällt dir an deutschland am
meisten ja ich würde sagen die vielfalt
in deutschland hat so man halt berlin
hamburg münchen eine kleine städte und
dann lässt also diese vielfalt manche so
sehr als ein spieler fand ich immer
langweilig in deutschland zu wohnen und
auch zu backen aber öfter ich reise nach
hause geht nicht zurück nach hause komme
denke ich okay es gibt ein paar sachen
die wir zu hause haben ja immer dies
waren das nicht so bei mir ist auch
immer so zum beispiel in deutschland mit
und dann komme ich wieder zurück nach
medianeinkommen sie solle endlich wieder
was ich an deutschland mag wirklich ist
die sicherheit
das hat man nicht in allen im winter
musste schon manchmal gucken wo du wann
er geht
aber so also im allgemeinen ist die
eigentlich ja ich will nicht sagen ist
unsicher aber du musst schon mehr
natürlich ja natürlich und in berlin
hast du auch plätze aber vielleicht
kenne ich jetzt einfach also meine
schirmer in berlin geklauten eine show
in berlin
das war ein schöner bergner recht okay
ansonsten mag ich noch in deutschland
die infrastruktur so würden was überall
züge und busse und straßen und kann's
also schüler öffnen vergessen wir das
ist ziemlich cool
ich weiß nur sachen die findet man nicht
unbedingt gut aber man ist trotzdem da
will ich daran gewöhnt in deutschland
wir sind so viel individuelle
eingestimmt und es ist immer wichtig was
man selber denkt und was man mag
was man kreisen ist herzlich jetzt doof
an aber für mich zum beispiel wichtig so
in namibia leute hängt immer
zusammenbringen so gerne auch mit leute
die du nicht kennst und dann kam mir so
oder gibt so viele leute dann feiern wir
das was wir nicht eigentlich gar das ist
das cool aber ich weiß auch dass ich
deutschland so ich brauche manchmal zeit
für mich natürlich
das ist irgendwie ein bisschen stolz und
in deutschland so ich habe meinen
eigenen space und ich muss dann formal
ankündigen wenn man kommt ja so und das
ist so nicht so jeder läuft immer in
mein haus rein und ich muss die ganze
abhängt das hat sich total ich das jetzt
sage weil das ich liebe das wirklich ein
anderer länder weil deutsche sind immer
sehr verklemmt und verschlossen
aber ich muss zugeben ich bin halb
deutsche ich kann es nicht aber kann das
nicht abstellen so ich brauche auch
immer meine ruhe für mich kalium kinder
im sonnenuntergang hab ich danke gesagt
er spielt gar kein fleisch sondern sowie
bild
also ich denke das hier ist kein fleisch
fleisch und dann wird getrocknet
es wird getrocknet nun an man ist
trocknet macht man so spices drauf und
dann tonnen man es in ein wenn es
getrocknet ist dann siehst du es einfach
so sieht das arbeiten was ist von felix
blume und das ist gut handel
schwierige frage also rufen generell
kann man sagen glaube ich das schon also
ein religion eher etwas privates in
deutschland deutschland ist also auf
jeden fall weniger religiös als amerika
oder auch die meisten afrikanischen
länder die ich kenne und es gibt aber
eher religionsunterricht in der schule
also das gibt es in katholisch und
evangelisch und auch werden gerade die
ersten lehrer ausgebildet für
islamischen religionsunterricht
also man kann das wählen man kann es ist
also seine eigene wahl
man kann religion in der schule nehmen
und dann kann man ganz normal
religionsunterricht haben aber es ist
nicht gar nicht so sehr findig ich hatte
auch religionsunterricht katholische
religion
es ist gar nicht so sehr fokussiert auf
immer nur deine eigene religion man
lernt auch viel allgemeinen über über
religionen verschiedene andere
religionen über praktischen extras 60
jahre und da er alternativ kann man aber
auch philosophie nehmen in manchen
ländern gibt es auch
ja das wird in den bundesländern auch
unterschiedlich gehandhabt also ich kann
dass man erzählen wie das in meiner
schule war ich hatte katholische
religion die nächste frage kommen von
berlin
66 sind außen 17
der ließ extra bailey 16 ist er mit ihr
meinte hallo carrefour dann wieder eine
tolle videos ich bring mir durch selbst
bei und ich finde sie sehr hilfreich ich
frage mich ob du weißt wie leicht es in
deutschland ist vegetarier oder veganer
zu sein und wie gängig sind diese lieben
stile
ich weiß dass sie deutschland bekannt
für ihren fleischkonsum sind aber ich
glaube dass umweltschutz auch beliebt
ist also werden diese lebensstile
beliebter vielen dank nochmal ja diese
frage hast du schon öfters gestellt und
nicht ob sie immer auf meiner liste
gehabt aber noch nie beantwortet also
heute beantworten heute in namibia im
fleisch land namibia weil sie dem also
tatsächlich mögen deutsche fleisch aber
auch nicht so sehr wie andere länder wie
zum beispiel in amerika nur fleisch eben
schon witze gemacht
hier gilt man kommt zum grill und auch
beim grillen in deutschland ist das
wirklich so einbringen salat eine
kartoffel
einer bringt gemüse eine rückfrage bei
uns wie bringt fleisch aber für alle
alle verschiedene fleisch sollte fleisch
jürgen also die qualität hier bestehen
nur aus fleisch in deutschland ist es
sehr populär vegetarier zu sein und auch
vegan wird populär man sieht dass in
großen städten mehr als in kleinen also
in vielen großen städten hast du eben in
den restaurants dann auch vegetarische
karten oder manchmal auch sogar vegane
gerichte oder du hast speziell berlin
sowieso ist es also märkten
biomärkte und berlin ist halt auch ein
bisschen hipster place also da haben wir
vegane restaurants auch vegetarische
restaurants und das ist vielleicht im
kleinen dörfern nicht so viel aber
grundsätzlich mich sagen es ist schon
sehr populär und auch einfach in
deutschland vegetarier zu sein
es gibt viele einkaufsgelegenheiten und
viele restaurants sonnenuntergang in
namibia noch eine frage zwei fragen ja
und zwar von muss mustafa als war 97er
meinte warum gehen sie in namibia was
macht ihr dort warum wir in namibia sind
was wir hier machen
eine gute frage ein sehr guter freund
hatte ich schon in den meisten videos
schon mal beantwortet wir sind hier
eingeladen worden vom goethe institut
wir fahren schon seit vielen jahren nach
namibia lieben das land
und gegen kopf ende auf dem kalender und
ihr ist ja sind dabei eingeladen worden
vom goethe-institut um workshops zu
machen und in diesen workshops auch
videos zu drehen mit schülern in der
media die deutschen dass ich toll er ist
passt sehr gut in die reden und wir
würden das gerne weitermachen denn wir
haben gemerkt dass uns das wahnsinnig
spaß macht und dass man auch deutsch
videos außerhalb von deutschland kann
laufen sie haben euch gefallen letzte
frage kalender von ardi kehren sie
wieder erkennen wie in asien austria ba
durch günstigsten by any change kann
jetzt kommt der witz jetzt kommt er ganz
große witz verfahren tatsächlich seit
einem jahr waren wir nicht mehr in wien
ich glaubs immer länger und jetzt kommen
wir fahren nach wien ich habe heute
markus wir fahren im juni als hättest du
es gewusst als hättest du es geahnt
wir sind ab dem elften oder zwölften
juni für ungefähr drei oder vier tage in
wien
schreibt uns unbedingt wenn du dort
wohnt dann treffen uns auf jeden fall
machen eine episode
und als letzter in die letzte video
haben wir in tschad gemacht heute nein
machen wir zwar wieder einen schaut her
aber das ist nur film mit matthias
matthias wehr ist das tut noch mal aus
wie matthias wien heißt matthias müller
matthias matthias ich fand ja und was
ist zweite shoutout also schaut to all
easy german fans das machen wir ja
niemals aber heute machen wir das halt
gibt löning germany bashing ist lernt ja
dann bist du schauen wir sehr schöne
grüße wir hoffen ihr könnt ihr das
überhaupt konnten uns überhaupt
verstehen hier am klang geräusch der
ganze musik hier an den ganzen lärm aber
aber es ist luxuslärm
ja wir sind euch die besten grüße in
namibia das war die letzte karte
nächstes mal sehen wir uns wieder ich
hab noch eins mit einem kleinen i sie
beantwortet habe ich ja immer versucht
freitags zu machen aber ich habe es
eigentlich nie geschafft deswegen werde
ich zwar weitermachen in zukunft aber
unregelmäßig machen also es kommt
einfach immer zwischendurch gar nicht
antwortet und das nächste mal seht ihr
kari antwortet wieder aus berlin aus
berlin